So, to summarize the Spinlock algorithm that we've seen
so far, we saw that the read spin on
read and spin on test and set and spin on test and set with a delay. All of
these spin algorithms, there's no fairness associated with them.
And if you think about the ticket lock algorithm,
it is fair but it is noisy. So, all of them are not quite there yet in terms of
our twin objectives of reducing latency and reducing
contention and if you think about it, let's
say that you know, that currently this T1
has got this lock. And all of these guys
are waiting for this lock to get released.
You know when T1 releases the lock, exactly one
of them is going to get it. Why should all of them be attempting to see if they,
they've got the lock. Ideally, what we would
want is that when T1 releases a lock.
Exactly one guy, one of these white reading
guys is, is a signal to indicate that
you've got the lock. Because exactly one guys
can, can get the lock to start with.
And therefore, ideally T1 should signal exactly on
the next thread and not all of them.
Now, this is the idea. Behind, queueing locks that you're going to see next.